big new fun idea today so to get there
as we so often do we need to take a step
back let's rewind a little bit we are in
this big topic which we started at the
end of last year and of course the topic
is called integration now integration is
a really big deal in mathematics it does
so many things it's as big as algebra in
some ways in terms of like how many
parts of mathematics relate to algebra
it's uh how many parts of that story
relate to algebra but it touches
everything integration is much the same
but we met at first in the context of
this question right we we realize that
areas could be solved particular kinds
of areas could be solved through
integration right so we would say that
the area bounded between a particular
curve and for example the x axis we
would write it in a particular way do
you remember how we wrote what would I
am what would I put on this integral
side I'll put some boundary some limits
right so I might say let's start here
and then let's go to there and then
after the integral sign after the limits
I would put two objects what two objects
would I put I would put the integrand
whatever it happens to be so for example
let's just say it's Y okay and then I
would put the the DX or the dy whatever
it happened to be which tells me what
which direction am I looking in what a
kind of integration am I doing here now
I want you to remember what these three
things are one two three because they
are all crucial to understanding what
we're about to do next the integral sign
sorry the the integral sign means like
it's a stretched-out will do I can that
we live form it's a stretched-out letter
s because what it's a sum now what is it
a sum of and the answer is these two
things multiplied together well one of
these represent your picture
say you got a function like this say y
equals x squared okay if I were to take
the area from I don't know some a to
some B then the thing I or the things
rather that I'm adding up are these tiny
infinitesimally thin rectangles right so
you can like sort of draw them in here
they are when they're so thin they look
like straight lines but they do have an
infinitesimal width right so now you
tell me again what are these two objects
that we're adding up they are the the
height multiplied by the width of the
rectangle does that make sense okay so
remember this we are summing and what we
are summing what we are adding up is
these rectangles each part of the
rectangle is important there's the
height there's the width okay so this is
what integration does this is what it
performs and we learned that amazingly
we can use the primitive function the
the reverse of the derivative function
we can use the period function to work
out what happened next
okay this is my point why why is it the
integration is so amazingly flexible and
can do so many things well it turns out
that often what we want to do is add up
a whole bunch of infinitesimally thin
things and that skill that ability is
useful in a wide variety of contexts
like say for example this one so I want
you to redraw this same curve just as an
example I could have done any okay then
I want you to take that same interval A
to B like that now if I were interested
in this area I know how to do that and I
heard you I'm just going to color this
in a slightly different color I would go
and do all these infinitesimally thin
rectangles no big deal but what I'm
going to suggest is something different
because we know how to do
so ready I want to imagine taking this
area and rotating it around an axis let
me say that again I want a picture
taking this area and rotating it around
an axis so sort of going to come out of
the board if I were to try and represent
it it would look something like this now
this is hard to picture which is why I
thought I would give you an illustration
of it okay now I'm I'm no Potter I tried
doing pottery actually when I was like
ten years seven or something like that
and that's how I know this is way harder
than it looks it usually just becomes
this mess of like goop in your head okay
but what is this guy doing what he's got
down here what is this thing doing it's
spinning spinning a real fast okay and
you can see his hands barely move his
hands barely move but because the disc
is spinning he creates this round shape
right he just holds it in place and it
molds the clay does that make sense and
you can see as he progresses so long as
he doesn't move too fast or lose control
he creates this symmetrical object but
it's not like reflectional symmetry
it's what kind of symmetries is its
rotational symmetry because the object
is made by rotation okay so you can see
he's created this solid and the solid of
course has a volume it's it's got some
substance to it
okay but the way he's made this solid is
by revolution by spinning by rotation
okay so we call this object he's almost
finished with it so inventor I'm just
trying to stall for him to actually
finish this ball we call this object
because it's a solid and it's been
formed by revolution very originally
here we go ah I missed the frame let's
go back that'll do
we call this object a solid of
revolution
right what we're interested in is what's
the volume of this thing how would you
work out how much clay he's actually
used that would be the volume of this
solid of revolution okay now come back
to the whiteboard let's think about
what's going on here and how there's a
parallel when you want to work out an
area what you add up is a whole bunch of
little rectangles yeah imagine taking
that strange shape which it's not a lot
of trapezium it's not a it's not on
anything it's not a sector if you like
that but it's a weird shape and I slice
it up as it were into these little you
know chunks okay does that make sense
now think about this object think about
this object if I were to take a similar
approach if I were to take this object
and slice it up into little itty pieces
I won't get rectangles anymore will I if
I slice this up I will get now it's
tempting to say circles it's very
tempting to say circles but remember
like how many how many dimensions does
this object have this this object has
two dimensions which is why when you
slice it up you get two-dimensional
objects rectangles right well this is
not a two-dimensional object it's
clearly a three-dimensional object so
when I slice it up I should get really
thin three-dimensional objects now what
would you call the circle if it had like
a little bit of thickness to it will be
a cylinder wouldn't it often the side
over here okay imagine I took a slice
right out the middle I can draw it over
here it's gonna look something like this
right here's like the cross-section okay
so from somewhere like here right here's
the cross-section but I have a tiny
little slice of it so it's gonna go like
this
not to scale but I can't draw it with
infinitesimally thin this so you just
have to deal with them okay so here is a
cylinder now I know how to deal with
cylinders the volume of every cylinder
is PI R squared H yeah now just before
we march forward cylinders are even
though it's not the proper name they're
basically like prisms aren't they
basically black prisms we don't call
them prisms because it doesn't have flat
edges but you've got a cross-section
and then you got a high just like every
other prism out there okay